what's going on guys this is Rob and
Wednesdays isn't really a dedicated
comic book day for us so what we're
going to start doing here at Comics
explain is we're going to take all the
comic book movie TV shows stuff that we
would normally talk about on geek
culture explain and we're going to talk
about it here on Comics explain because
honestly I'm burning myself out making
like 10 to 15 videos a week to the point
that I almost wanted to quit last week
so as a result of that what I'm going to
do in this video is I want to basically
make sense of everything going on with
Kane to conqueror and he who remains and
the Multiverse and all that kind of
stuff because that seems to confuse a
lot of the casual moviegoers and TV show
fans that are out there and then I want
to put forward a theory of how we're
going to see Chris Evans Captain America
again and actually his involvement here
is going to take place during the time
when he was basically putting the
Infinity Stones back at the end of
Avengers end game so let's make sense of
all this stuff right let's make sense of
all these things so here's how all this
plays out in the beginning there was
just the Multiverse that was basically
how it came into existence doesn't
really matter what does matter is that
in every single Universe of across the
Multiverse in the 31st Century there was
a guy named Nathaniel Richards that's
probably the single most important thing
that we're going to talk about here and
the reason why is because in every
Universe each one of these Nathaniel
Richards realized that their Universe
was part of the greater Multiverse and
so what they ended up doing was
exploring the Multiverse they literally
met alternate reality versions of each
other but what ended up happening here
is some of these versions of Nathaniel
Richards realize they could conquer the
Multiverse whereas other ones wanted to
explore and be Defenders of it so quite
literally good guys and bad guys and so
what this did is it led to the
multiversal war literally all these
different versions of Nathaniel facing
off against each other now realizing
that this war would destroy the entirety
of the Multiverse one of these versions
of Nathaniel weaponized a cosmic entity
and then used that power to obliterate
every single Universe in the Multiverse
except for his own that Universe being
the main Marvel Cinematic Universe right
Earth 616 as we call it now and so
following this act of wiping out the
Multiverse and preserving its own
Universe this guy took off to the very
end of time kind of outside of time and
he started calling himself he who
remains in turn he created the time
variance Authority and realizing that
the return of the Multiverse in an
unchecked manner where it's just any
number of alternate realities coming
into existence out there that it would
basically lead to the return of his evil
versions that what he ended up doing was
using the TVA as a means to destroy any
alternate reality that did not lead to
the creation of him and so the TVA did
this for eons for who in the hell knows
how long but this goes into the events
of Loki when ultimately Loki and one of
his variants Sylvie discover he who
remains and so when that happened when
they're sitting in that room and they're
talking to Jonathan Major's character he
gave them two options he said either you
can take over for me and ensure that
this sacred timeline this small number
of universe verses in the Multiverse
stays intact and you don't have to worry
about evil versions of Kings showing up
or you can kill me you can let the
Multiverse just kind of spiral out to
its natural state and then you got to
worry about my variance and ultimately
Sylvie betrayed Loki and then decided to
kill he who remains allowing the
Multiverse to come back now having said
all of that that's what gets us right
here to where we are with basically
Ant-Man and wasp quantumania there are
questions that we do not have answers to
for example how did this version of King
the Conqueror get here is he the only
one are there other versions of King
that exist out there in the Multiverse
that are part of this giant Council of
Kings did this version of King that
we're going to see in Ant-Man wasp
quantumania did he kill all the other
kings and he's the only one left these
are things that we don't know we won't
have an answer to this question until we
get to this movie and probably not even
until we get to Loki season 2. this will
probably answer all those different
things but I do have a bit of a theory
on this I'm not going to go super in
depth into it but one of the things that
we could argue here or that we could say
potentially happened is that when the
Multiverse came back all those different
versions of King came along with it but
the history is still intact history is
still the same right it's a
chronological series of events
multiversal War he who remains Inns it
he forms the TVA he controls the
timeline silly kills he who remains now
the Multiverse is bad don't which means
that in any of these alternate realities
a version of Nathaniel Richards this
came to conqueror that we're going to
see in Ant-Man and wasp quantumania he
could look over the entire history of
the time stream which includes his own
destruction or how it was that he who
remains wiped out the Multiverse in the
first multiversal war this could give
him an idea and say okay what if I did
that instead what if I go all the way
back to the very beginning of time to
the very beginning of the multiversal
war and instead of HE who remained using
Elias to basically Wipe Out the entirety
of the Multiverse I do it I weaponize
this Cosmic entity and I wipe out out
all the Multiverse except for a
collection of universes or for my own
universe and now I'm the one running the
show if this was the case it would
answer a few different questions for
example at the end of the Loki TV show
one of the things that a lot of people
Miss is that when Loki sent back to the
TVA headquarters by Sylvie there's a
huge change that goes on there the first
is that we know that instead of the
statues of the TVA that is statues of
Kane the Conqueror that when you have
him meeting with Mobius and B15 they
don't know who he is whereas they
previously did this basically means that
Kane the Conqueror has already changed
history he's already changed the
timeline but the bigger hit that this
has came to conqueror running the show
is that right before Loki gets to Mobius
in B15 when they're talking amongst each
other they're talking about all these
different branches coming off of the
main timeline and Moby has the same
things like does he want it to be this
way like why does he want the universes
to Branch out that kind of thing
basically indicating that Mobius knows
there's one guy one in the show this is
important because in the Loki TV show
before everything was changed before he
who remains was killed Mobius didn't
know about he who remains he didn't know
about the whole lie of the timekeepers
hence the reason why Loki was racing
back to Mobius to tell him everything he
wouldn't need to tell him everything if
Mobius already knew so it's that kind of
a thing so the question that we have
here is how exactly would this work well
I think it works in the same way of like
a meteor crashing into Earth right a
meteor smashes into Earth and what you
end up getting is like tidal waves just
kind of branching out in every direction
right like we were just spreading out in
every single Direction so we can use
that analogy here we can say that this
meteor whatever event caused it to set
on a course where it was going to crash
into Earth that is Sylvie killing he
remains the meteor crashing into Earth
is Kang going back in time weaponizing
Alias or eliaith or whatever and then
killing the entirety of the Multiverse
changing the time string the tidal wave
is the effect of that action spreading
along the time stream so by the time
Loki was pushed back to the TBA
headquarters by Sylvie that tidal wave
had already passed over the TVA and so
it was already shifted it had already
changed quite literally if Loki had
gotten there at that point in time
before the Title Wave hit you actually
probably would have seen that change
happening in real time you would have
seen the statues of the TVA being
removed and replaced with the statues of
King that Mobius suddenly would have
been like who are you right like mint
conversation okay Loki so here's what
we're gonna do
who the hell are you you know like
literally just like that like you would
see that shift happen in real time which
honestly I think they should have done
it would have made everything clear for
the the general audience but having said
that I hope that little bit makes sense
right there I hope it kind of brings
Clarity to this otherwise confusing
situation again there's a lot of
questions that we don't have answers to
the idea of Kang going into the past and
changing everything we don't
definitively know if that's true we'll
probably end up finding out an Ant-Man
that was quantumania but we don't have
an absolute answer here now one of the
things that I've been saying here when
it comes to the whole idea of King
Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars is that
this is basically going to be Avengers
forever right it'll be done by a
different name and it may include
elements of battle world but it's going
to be Avengers forever this is going to
be a series of films that are basically
going to focus on bringing together an
Avengers team a multiversal Avengers
team that includes members who have been
plucked from the time stream so
literally what Marvel could do is say
okay Captain America is going into the
past he's gonna put the Infinity Stones
back to where they're supposed to be but
then he's recruited by Loki Loki's like
hey Cat we got a great big huge problem
came the conqueror's back he's trying to
destroy the whole Multiverse we need
your help we're forming a multiversal
Avengers team and let's say that he's
met by like Robert Downey Jr's Iron Man
maybe like right when he first became
Iron Man as opposed to when he died
during the events of Avengers end game
maybe he's met by like a future version
of Captain America I mean in the trailer
you do see a point where it's basically
like a bajillion Ant-Man so the idea of
there being multiple variants of
existing Heroes that we know that are
going to appear over the course of both
this movie and possibly future movies
that's not out of a question I imagine
this movie will be confined to Ant-Man
and you'll see multiple versions of
Scott Lang but it's literally Marvel
easing us into this that's what they've
done if you look at the bigger picture
it's what they've done here Avengers end
game eased us into time travel Loki and
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness as
well as Marvel what if has eased us into
the concept of alternate realities and
different versions of the same hero
across the entirety of the Multiverse
literally this is just the next logical
step hey guys here's an Avengers team
with Captain America from this universe
but it's actually Scott Lang instead of
Chris Evans right that kind of a thing
right so it's entirely possible they
could do that but having said that let
me know what you guys think about this
right let me know what you guys think
about this possibility but thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later peace